thank you all very very much my goodness  I I don't know what we'd have done  tonight if we'd actually won I want to  begin by congratulating senator Sanders  on his victory tonight and I want to  thank each and every one of you and I  want to say i still love New Hampshire  and I always will now we take this  campaign to the entire country we are  going to fight for every vote in every  state we're going to fight for real  solutions that make a real difference in  people's lives be what is the best way  to change people's lives so we can all  grow together who is the best change  maker and here's what I promise here's  what I promise I will work harder than  anyone to actually make the changes that  make your lives better in this campaign  you've heard a lot about Washington and  about Wall Street now senator Sanders  and I both want to get secret  unaccountable money out of politics and  I will fight to rein in Wall Street and  you know what I know how to do it